everyone has a body clock that affects
when we sleep what our moods like and
researchers believe it now also plays a
part in breast cancer with morning
people less likely to get it compared to
night owls ticking off experiences on
her bucket list it was back in 2015 that
Heidi was told she had up to five years
to live
she's been working for the police at the
time which involved a lot of night
shifts but her cancer spread when she
was pregnant and was unable to get the
full treatment that she needed for sure
somebody that gets consistent sleep is
definitely better for that how physical
and mental without doubt which you know
if you're if you're feeling completely
drained and completely stressed it
affects your immune system it would I
put that down to what gave me breast
cancer being somebody that worked night
shifts in the police for years on end no
probably not I just think it's one of
those things that happened one in seven
women will develop breast cancer in
their lifetime and latest research by
Bristol University shows morning people
a forty to forty eight percent less
likely to get it those who slept longer
than seven to eight hours a night
increase their chances of being
diagnosed by 20% per additional hour
spent sleeping we really do need to look
more into the potential mechanisms by
which a morning person might be at the
reduced risk and so in particular we
might want to look at the role of
potential hormones and the role of
hormonal regulation and which can lead
to breast cancer so just how important
is the amount of sleep that we actually
get sleep is fundamental to having good
health and not only that to preserving
life so the most important things are
the length of sleep which needs to be
nearer eight hours than what it is for
most of the people and the second thing
is it needs to be at the right time the
likes of Heidi believe that staying
positive and leading a healthy lifestyle
is crucial to the way that she feels but
of course with the pressures of
stressful busy working lives the worry
is that that can have an impact not only
on our body clock but indeed our health
rebecca williams skinny
in Bristol